uh speaking of race and race-baiting and
racism
there was an attempt at a follow-up
white nationalist alt-right rally
yesterday in washington d.c
you might remember a year ago in
charlottesville virginia
there was a horrible horrible white
supremacist white separatist alt-right
rally
it led to the death of heather heyer
heather hayer i always say that
incorrectly higher it is higher i just
never remember what it is
uh the president the current president
of the united states said that there
were very fine people on both sides of
that white
nationalist white supremacist alt-right
rally in charlottesville virginia a year
ago
we're now at the one-year anniversary
and of course this is
exactly the type of event we would
remember
with a moment of silence not another
white nationalist rally but there were
white nationalists who wanted another
rally so they were going to do it this
weekend they were going to do it sunday
and in terms of turnout it failed
hilariously and miserably apparently
somewhere between a couple dozen and 50
actual alt-right white nationalist
supporters showed up
there were way more counter-protesters
and police officers and even just media
people covering it
way outnumbering the actual white
nationalist alt-rightists and
i want to sort of make the point that
just because there was low turnout at
this event
doesn't mean that there's no longer
white supremacy that has been
reinvigorated by the presidency of
donald trump it doesn't mean that
there's no longer
horrible vile people in this country
they didn't show up to the rally but
that doesn't mean that they don't exist
and of course we know they exist and we
know that they've been emboldened by the
presidency of donald trump
we actually had someone on the ground
there joshua turner who you might
remember because he's a former neo-nazi
who i've interviewed on the show
he's part of an organization called
saved by reason and he emailed me
and he said quote about 50 unite the
right guys came and there were over 10
000 counter protesters the police had
them separated
and everything went down peacefully i
filmed with newsy the entire time got to
talk to some neo-nazis one-on-one
they were happy the protest turned out
peacefully but they were basically
drowned out from the counter protesters
and left early the second it started to
drizzle
so it rained on their parade literally
uh and that was about it so
it was a failure it was a failure in
terms of being this
sort of public show of support for
alt-rightism or white nationalism or
whatever
i find the most interesting thing about
this entire
one-year anniversary rally uh to be
how media was unsure
about if and how they should cover it of
course
right wing media mostly provided cover
for the fact that this was a white
supremacist rally so a couple of
examples of that lease power
from media matters had some funny lower
third screenshots from fox and friends
where they forgot to mention that it was
a white nationalist rally one lower
third
during fox and friends said antifa
demands an
end to america they had another headline
antifa protesters chant no borders in dc
what about the fact that it was white
nationalists
commemorating charlottesville where a
woman
died yeah apparently they couldn't be
expected to do that okay so that was one
thing and we we sort of expected that
coverage from right wing media
but the more interesting thing is that
there is a debate
about should we de-platform white
nationalists versus should we challenge
them on their ideas and interview them
this is a debate we've dealt with a lot
because of my interviews with all kinds
of extremists the westboro baptist
church white nationalist richard spencer
homophobes racists
so on and so forth and the debate that
is had is usually the wrong debate the
debate is usually david
these people should not be interviewed
period or
merely interviewing them exposes their
bad ideas
i believe that the responsible approach
is what stephen bennell ii
also known to some of you as destiny in
the online gaming world
calls responsible platforming which
means
if you interview the racists or the
extremists or whoever you have to
understand
it's not always obvious to the audience
that their ideas are bad
racist discriminatory ideas they want to
do the interview
because they want any platform to be
used
to get these ideas out there and maybe
someone will be convinced by their ideas
so
simply saying to them tell me why you're
a racist
tell me why jews are the problem in all
of the world whatever
and having them tell you why that
doesn't expose them that's not
responsible platforming responsible
platforming
means you're prepared to challenge their
ideas not in a screaming and yelling way
we don't yell and scream on this program
but with thoughtful well-crafted
questions where you've researched what
their likely responses are going to be
so that you can interrupt their use of
your platform for propaganda purposes
that's what i try to do
i don't think i always succeed pat at
least not as well as i want to
but there's this middle ground between
they should be completely de-platformed
and we pretend their ideas don't exist
that doesn't work because that actually
can provide cover for their ideas
to to catalyze and to metastasize the
other side is
just interviewing them is bad for them
because it exposes their bad ideas
responsible platforming is the path
forward yeah i mean i think in most
corporate outlets the reporters will
either try to go for the gotcha question
to catch them in like some sound bite
that's not going to play out well for
them sure
or they don't know which questions to
ask and they don't know how to push them
effectively because
they're not used to asking very pressing
questions if they're interviewing a
politician they don't want to uh
say something that will cause them
access in the future so
it's more about practice than anything
else yeah they don't want to lose access
and i think that that is a big priority
for how corporate media handles
interviews with big politicians and and
bigger names and i think that that is
it's sort it's a false debate that was
mostly had around this it's not so much
about
whether to interview the extremists but
about how to interview them
interviewing them in and of itself isn't
what needs to be debated
how it should be done is the important
conversation and
a lot of bogus discussion centered
around this rally send me your thoughts
how do you define responsible
platforming i'm on twitter
deepakman and the show is on twitter at
davidpakmanshow
today's episode of the show is made
possible in part by filter
easy you can outsmart your chore list by
signing up for filter easy it's a
subscription service
that will make it impossible for you to
forget to change your air filters
because they arrive at your front door
when you need to change them as some of
you know i recently moved
and i had a list of about i don't know
100 to 150 things that had to be done
and one of them was figuring out
the right schedule for filter
replacements and now that i am signed up
with filter easy
i get the new filters on the schedule
that they need to be replaced at my
place
a lot of homeowners don't know how often
to change their air filters or they
forget and filter easy makes it
very very simple you can sign up in
under five minutes on your computer or
phone
it's extraordinarily easy and i am now
fully set up with filter easy and it's a
subscription for something you actually
need
versus lots of other things that you can
sign up for it's practical
it's really a no-brainer which is why i
sign up for it and for listeners and
viewers of the david pakman show
you can get your first order for free by
going to filtereasy.com
if you prefer to do it by phone you can
call 855 910
easy that's seven nine either way
please use the coupon code pacman that
is p a k
m a n offer code pacman sign up today at
filtereasy.com to get your first order
free
or call 855 855-910-3279 don't forget
the offer code it's p-a-k-m-a-n